Jake:这边导出
Jake: Export this side
Nicous: 是不是啊
Nicous: Right?
Choiszt: 不是他有
Choiszt: No, he has it
Choiszt: 杨梅是杨梅是
Choiszt: Yangmei, it's Yangmei
Nicous: 就这
Nicous: Just this
Choiszt: theveger
Choiszt: Theveger
Nicous: 手刚开一点儿
Nicous: Just opened a bit
Choiszt: 额不能弄
Choiszt: Uh, can't do it
Katrina: 太难了
Katrina: Too hard
Choiszt: 就是四种拍的之后就是我们要照着
Choiszt: It's just four types, then we need to follow
Jake:照着播回来
Jake: Follow and broadcast back
Nicous: 行
Nicous: Okay
Choiszt: 可是他为什么是这种电池电线
Choiszt: But why is it this kind of battery and wire
Choiszt: 需要换电池
Choiszt: Need to change the battery
Nicous: 啊我换个电池
Nicous: Ah, I'll change the battery
Choiszt: 这个电池还行 他这个白的
Choiszt: This battery is okay, it's white
Katrina: 自己扒吧这个
Katrina: Do it yourself then
Nicous: 没插电
Nicous: Not plugged in
Jake:不补 为什么
Jake: No supplement, why?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey
Jake:他他没反应
Jake: He didn't respond
Katrina: 咱们要见面一下吧
Katrina: Let's meet up for a bit
Choiszt: 换个电池吗
Choiszt: Change the battery?
Jake:你可以学会画
Jake: You can learn to draw
Choiszt: 不是电池的问
Choiszt: It's not the battery's issue
Katrina: 可以啊
Katrina: Sure
Alice:奎因卡
Alice: Quinnka
Nicous: 我怎么看不上
Nicous: I can't see it
Jake:刚才是没保存是吗
Jake: Was it not saved just now?
Choiszt: 没有没有
Choiszt: No, no
Jake:开过之后他就不显示那个下边了
Jake: After opening, it doesn't show the bottom part anymore
Nicous: 定定过
Nicous: Fixed it
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Choiszt: 从看一组
Choiszt: From watching a group
Nicous: 哈哈
Nicous: Haha
Jake:你把你把就只你只要保证这个
Jake: You just need to ensure this
Nicous: 他不是这个应该
Nicous: It's not this
Choiszt: 他这个因该啊
Choiszt: It should be
Jake:应该啊
Jake: It should be
Nicous: 那边明显是
Nicous: That side is obvious
Choiszt: 差不多也就是开始做他就
Choiszt: Almost like he just started doing it and then
Jake:看出来他这个做多长
Jake: You can see how long he does this
Jake:做这个显示头
Jake: Doing this display head
Nicous: 头太长了
Nicous: The head is too long
Choiszt: 喂喂
Choiszt: Hey, hey
Choiszt: 就是敲门也没有用是吧
Choiszt: Knocking doesn't work, right?
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes
Nicous: 哈哈哈
Nicous: Hahaha
Choiszt: 机器坏了
Choiszt: The machine is broken
Katrina: missing missing 丢了
Katrina: The main thing is missing
Nicous: 使劲敲
Nicous: Hit it hard
Nicous: 卧槽你也会
Nicous: Wow, you can do it too
Katrina: 下午干啥排舞啊
Katrina: What are we doing in the afternoon, dance rehearsal?
Choiszt: 排舞然后
Choiszt: Dance rehearsal and then
Katrina: 还买东西呢
Katrina: And also shopping
Choiszt: 啥还买东西
Choiszt: What, shopping too?
Katrina: 就是这个东西
Katrina: Yeah, this thing
Katrina: 有的东西是4点前就当天发货这种哈哈
Katrina: Some stuff ships on the same day if ordered before 4 PM, haha
Choiszt: 可以买
Choiszt: We can buy it
Katrina: 不是还要我们讨论一下
Katrina: Don't we need to discuss
Katrina: 每个房间的主题吗
Katrina: The theme for each room?
Choiszt: 对对对
Choiszt: Yes, yes
Katrina: 你得在这写
Katrina: You need to write it here
Choiszt: 这儿，听过
Choiszt: Here, listen
Choiszt: 又又多又杂就好好好的不得了
Choiszt: It's so much, it's so varied, it's really great
Katrina: 唉原来你喜欢这样
Katrina: Oh, so you like it this way
Choiszt: 表情但是好
Choiszt: The expression is good though
Nicous: 就是这样那个
Nicous: It's like that, you know
Katrina: 哎颜色看是哪个版本来着
Katrina: Hey, which version is the color?
Katrina: 难道早上看的是这个版本
Katrina: Did we see this version in the morning?
Nicous: 你拨打的这个就是这个
Nicous: The one you dialed is this one
Katrina: 我感觉看
Katrina: I feel like
Choiszt: hello
Choiszt: Hello
Katrina: 呲但我看的不是这版本
Katrina: But the one I saw wasn’t this version
Choiszt: 这个口子我记得他不是比有和解得好弹吗
Choiszt: I remember this slot isn't as flexible as the reconciliation one
Jake:不是
Jake: No
Nicous: 不是和田一共就这么几个么
Nicous: Aren't there just a few of them in Hetian?
Katrina: my my dream my my dream
Katrina: My my dream, my my dream
Nicous: 你多按都按几遍这个
Nicous: You press it multiple times
Jake:这个需要你分脑的高起点
Jake: This requires a high starting point for your brain
Katrina: 呲呲呲呲呲
Katrina: Ssss
Katrina: isgodlife
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Damn
Katrina: 真是这版本啊
Katrina: It's really this version?
Choiszt: 卧槽真的没电
Choiszt: Oh crap, there's really no power
Choiszt: 别刚停电
Choiszt: Don't just lose power
Katrina: 我靠太
Katrina: Damn, too
Choiszt: 你们可以开始拍了
Choiszt: You guys can start filming now
Jake:你们录吧
Jake: You guys record
Jake:另外各位请康请
Jake: Also, everyone, please enjoy
Choiszt: 开始录我看一下不等
Choiszt: Start recording, I'll take a look, don't wait
Katrina: 左手还是右手
Katrina: Left hand or right hand?
Choiszt: 2024
Choiszt: 03
Choiszt: 我这04
Choiszt: Mine is 04
Jake:04117
Jake: 04117
Choiszt: -0525
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright
Choiszt: 杠×X
Choiszt: Bar ×X
Choiszt: 杠
Choiszt: Bar
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright
Choiszt: 杠
Choiszt: Bar
Shure: Vwilevcomeinfabo
Choiszt: 这个是谁啊
Choiszt: Who is this?
Shure: OK我给拔了我给他插上
Shure: OK, I'll unplug it and plug it back in
Shure: OK所以我现在可以去做咖啡了吗杨老板
Shure: OK, so can I go make coffee now, Jake?
Jake:可以做咖啡了
Jake: You can make coffee now
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay
Jake:去吧
Jake: Go ahead
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Choiszt: 现在他们就开始拍了
Choiszt: They're starting to film now
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 去做咖啡
Shure: Go make coffee
Choiszt: 就现在是fishion
Choiszt: So now it's fishion
Choiszt: 多亏了你们
Choiszt: Thanks to you guys
Choiszt: 我操我他妈怂死了
Choiszt: Damn, I was so scared
Choiszt: 哈哈哈我等了两天
Choiszt: Haha, I waited two days
Choiszt: 我操走散完全了
Choiszt: Damn, completely lost
Choiszt: 我操这之前都是就是只能开个眼镜
Choiszt: Damn, before this, I could only open a pair of glasses
Choiszt: 然后现在我很怕
Choiszt: And now I'm really scared
Choiszt: 等我半点下睡觉
Choiszt: Wait for me, I'll sleep at half past.
Nicous: 你看这个都起来
Nicous: Look, this is all up.
Choiszt: 没有没有他这个直接坐这儿
Choiszt: No, no, he's just sitting here.
Choiszt: 他这个跟戳九点来了
Choiszt: He came right at nine o'clock.
Jake:九点
Jake: Nine o'clock?
Jake:额别的还有什么
Jake: Um, what else?
Nicous: 就这个负责拆分学校
Nicous: Just responsible for splitting the school.
Jake:三星手机他就
Jake: Samsung phones, and he...
Jake:别倒腾
Jake: Don't mess with it.
Nicous: 手机之家
Nicous: Mobile Home.
Jake:手机之家读个创
Jake: Mobile Home, read for innovation.
Katrina: 34
Katrina: 34.
Choiszt: 看你手机其实卡的一逼
Choiszt: Look, your phone is actually lagging a lot.
Jake:就是那种苹果客户之家也是可以的
Jake: Yeah, it's that kind of Apple customer home, it's fine.
Choiszt: 那个支架感觉更细一点儿
Choiszt: That stand looks a bit thinner.
Choiszt: 就新到的
Choiszt: Just arrived.
Nicous: 这他妈的得学多久
Nicous: How long does it take to learn this shit?
Katrina: 不知道哇
Katrina: No idea.
Nicous: 太慢了有个快进
Nicous: Too slow, there's a fast forward.
Choiszt: 我看现在到了有鬼
Choiszt: I see it now, there's something spooky.
Choiszt: 来到进去
Choiszt: Come in.
Nicous: ;哇这一个人确实感觉
Nicous: Wow, this person really feels...
Choiszt: 我靠你知道我要怎么过的么
Choiszt: Damn, do you know how I got through?
Katrina: 哈哈哼
Katrina: Haha, oh.
Katrina: 再说要哭了
Katrina: Say it again and I'll cry.
Jake:这不已经已经无语是吗哈哈哈
Jake: Aren't you already speechless? Hahaha.
Choiszt: 走了
Choiszt: Let's go.
Nicous: 无所谓你这边你先
Nicous: Whatever, you go first.
Jake:哎这个可以这个可以
Jake: Hey, this works, this works.
Jake:就我们这我光抄我光开相机我他妈的
Jake: Just us here, I only copy, I only turn on the camera, damn it.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈你懂吗
Choiszt: Hahaha, you understand?
Jake:是是是每天至少来一个吧
Jake: Yes, yes, at least one a day.
Shure: 你们在干嘛
Shure: What are you guys doing?
Choiszt: 保存导入
Choiszt: Save and import.
Jake:我们有这个
Jake: We have this.
Shure: 做咖啡
Shure: Making coffee.
Choiszt: 我这个给你一下
Choiszt: I'll give you this.
Choiszt: 这上边不不不是这个
Choiszt: This on top, no, not this one.
Choiszt: 啊哈我这个时髦对开
Choiszt: Ah ha, I'm so trendy!
Katrina: 咱真的跳这么难的吗
Katrina: Are we really doing such a hard dance?
Nicous: 你们这边都跳过
Nicous: You've all done it here.
Katrina: 我有跳过
Katrina: I have done it.
Katrina: 但是他们有两个没跳过舞的
Katrina: But two of them haven't danced before.
Katrina: 他这动作还挺碎的
Katrina: His moves are pretty sharp.
Katrina: 还挺快得嘞
Katrina: Pretty fast too.
Alice:是不是一个男的
Alice: Is it a guy?
Katrina: 那么咱就跳这
Katrina: Then let's do this dance.
Katrina: 有事有活干了
Katrina: We have something to do now.
Katrina: 我说要学这个舞的话这两天有活干
Katrina: I mean, if we want to learn this dance, we'll be busy these days.
Shure: 没有没有没有还有下一步
Shure: No, no, no, there's another step.
Jake:上去因为上边有那个就是音响设备
Jake: Go up because there's the sound equipment.
Jake:这个动作很厉害
Jake: This move is really cool.
Katrina: 这也大家一起看
Katrina: Let's all watch this together.
Jake:就是他通过八拍把你那个
Jake: It's like he does it in eight beats.
Katrina: 真的吗这么厉害
Katrina: Really, that's amazing.
Jake:你看着这个可以试试
Jake: You can try watching this.
Jake:你在从新一两分做的
Jake: Start over from one or two minutes.
Katrina: 分解教学
Katrina: Step-by-step teaching.
Jake:这个确实适合学一学啊
Jake: This is really worth learning.
Choiszt: 这个是一次性加多少
Choiszt: How much do we add at once?
Choiszt: 加到20克
Choiszt: Add up to 20 grams.
Shure: 呃15克的豆子240克的水
Shure: Uh, 15 grams of beans and 240 grams of water.
Choiszt: 240克对
Choiszt: 240 grams, right.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 学吧来吧挑战
Katrina: Let's learn it, come on, challenge accepted.
Shure: 我刚想说手术到级结果多了0.3颗
Shure: I just wanted to say the surgery level and it ended up with 0.3 more.
Shure: 问题不大然后剩下就等他
Shure: It's not a big deal, just wait for it.
Shure: 等等他滤一
Shure: Wait for it to filter.
Shure: 般都是1:15 啊
Shure: Usually it's 1:15.
Shure: 1:16吧好像是
Shure: 1:16, I think.
Shure: 好这种
Shure: Okay, this kind.
Choiszt: 卧槽
Choiszt: Whoa.
Shure: 这不能对
Shure: This can't be right.
Choiszt: 没有奶咖什么的咖啡这种对于
Choiszt: No milk coffee or something like that, right?
Shure: 他不是不是浓缩的才可以对
Shure: It's not, only espresso will do.
Choiszt: 他那个里面有只
Choiszt: There's only...
Shure: 行差不多了
Shure: Okay, that's about right.
Shure: 嗯真就我的因为我送你的
Shure: Yeah, really, because I sent it to you.
Shure: 你的也还好
Shure: Yours is okay too.
Katrina: 一起吧一起学吧
Katrina: Let's do it together, let's learn together.
Alice:不会
Alice: No way.
Katrina: 我我也没学过这舞试一下
Katrina: I haven't learned this dance before either, let's give it a try.
Katrina: 试一下吧
Katrina: Let's give it a try.
Alice:我敢想象我跳这个会有多么的扭曲
Alice: I can imagine how twisted I'll look dancing this.
Shure: 是的这都是浅红的豆子
Shure: Yes, these are all light red beans.
Shure: 然后所以就果香会多一些
Shure: So, it has more of a fruity aroma.
Shure: 果香花香
Shure: Fruity and floral.
Shure: 像那个咖啡店那种
Shure: Like those coffee shops.
Shure: 直接做美式的Espresso
Shure: Where they make Americanos directly with Espresso.
Shure: 那种都是深红的
Shure: Those are all dark red.
Shure: 就是它基本只剩苦味了
Shure: They basically only have a bitter taste left.
Nicous: 每次他就是所系所
Nicous: Every time, he's like...
Shure: 是它就是Espresso加水就叫
Shure: Yes, Espresso with water is called...
Choiszt: 还有浓缩就是什么意思
Choiszt: And what does "concentrated" mean?
Shure: 浓缩就是咖啡机弄出来的
Shure: "Concentrated" means what the coffee machine makes.
Shure: 大概这么一勺子的
Shure: It's about a spoonful.
Shure: 就类似于你喝酒那勺子杯
Shure: Like the spoon you use for drinking.
Shure: 一勺子的咖啡液对
Shure: A spoonful of coffee liquid, yes.
Choiszt: 咖啡豆是
Choiszt: Coffee beans are...
Shure: 就是演演示一下磨成粉
Shure: Just grind them into powder.
Shure: 然后放到一个这么样的
Shure: Then put them in something like this.
Shure: 一个一个粉碗里
Shure: In a powder bowl.
Shure: 然后给他压成饼然后上到机器上
Shure: Then press it into a cake and put it in the machine.
Shure: 然后他开始压出来那么一点浓缩液
Shure: Then it starts to press out a little bit of concentrate.
Nicous: 卧槽有点太酸了
Nicous: Wow, it's a bit too sour.
Nicous: 不是不像咖啡味我觉得像
Nicous: It doesn't taste like coffee, I think it tastes like...
Katrina: 你们泡的是哪个呀
Katrina: Which one did you brew?
Katrina: 泡那个云南那个吗
Katrina: The one from Yunnan?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 来来来尝尝
Shure: Come, try it.
Katrina: 云南那个很酸
Katrina: The Yunnan one is very sour.
Shure: 我自己手冲的尝一口
Shure: Try the one I brewed by hand.
Katrina: 尝尝
Katrina: Try it.
Shure: 可以发为了
Shure: It's good.
Katrina: 早上那个云南的也很酸
Katrina: The Yunnan one this morning was also very sour.
Shure: 算
Shure: Yes.
Choiszt: 可以等会儿咖啡
Choiszt: Can we have coffee later?
Katrina: 尝尝怎么首充
Katrina: Try it, how to brew by hand.
Katrina: 就是你把它倒了
Katrina: Just pour it out.
Katrina: 这张倒
Katrina: Pour this one out.
Shure: 不是什么叫倒
Shure: What do you mean by "pour"?
Katrina: 哈哈哈我以为是你
Katrina: Hahaha, I thought it was you.
Shure: 你在说什么
Shure: What are you talking about?
Choiszt: 卧槽给他喝一口看
Choiszt: Whoa, let him take a sip and see.
Shure: 拿这个就那么那么那么一点点浇上去
Shure: Just pour a tiny bit of this on it.
Shure: 就这种
Shure: Like this.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈
Choiszt: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哦懂了
Katrina: Oh, got it.
Katrina: 感觉得灌很多牛奶啊
Katrina: Feels like a lot of milk is needed.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 哎呦
Katrina: Oh dear.
Choiszt: 到底是什么人啊这个
Choiszt: Who is this guy anyway?
Shure: 我哈哈哈
Shure: Me, hahaha.
Choiszt: 哎你有点太算了
Choiszt: Hey, you're a bit too...
Choiszt: 我有点起不来太苦味
Choiszt: I can't handle it, it's too bitter.
Katrina: 相当于口服液
Katrina: It's like an oral solution.
Choiszt: 确实
Choiszt: Indeed.
Shure: 咖啡豆后天到
Shure: The coffee beans will arrive the day after tomorrow.
Shure: 这个确实有点太酸了
Shure: This is really too sour.
Katrina: 牛奶在下面
Katrina: The milk is at the bottom.
Choiszt: 所以我他妈回味里面只有酸为这辈子
Choiszt: So the aftertaste in my mouth is only sour, damn.
Shure: 这个杯子是你的
Shure: This cup is yours.
Choiszt: 让我来职位不易
Choiszt: Let me have the position, it's not easy.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Choiszt: 可以吗
Choiszt: Is it okay?
Shure: 可以你可以感觉一下这个感觉
Shure: Yes, you can feel it out.
Shure: 味道其实差不多
Shure: The taste is actually similar.
Shure: 会比刚才淡一些
Shure: Just a bit milder than before.
Choiszt: 对没有那个那么酸
Choiszt: Yeah, not as sour as before.
Choiszt: 但是咖啡味还是有的
Choiszt: But the coffee flavor is still there.
Shure: 这个把这个绿纸拿
Shure: Take this green paper away.
Shure: 哎呦呦呦他在低
Shure: Oh, it's dripping.
Choiszt: 里面这个可以喝吗
Choiszt: Can we drink this inside?
Shure: 不可以不是没没有这么喝的
Shure: No, you can't drink it like that.
Shure: 就跟你泡茶倒茶台
Shure: It's like when you brew tea and pour it into the tea tray.
Shure: 茶台里的
Shure: Into the tea tray.
Katrina: 我们这里有
Katrina: We have it here.
Katrina: 我们镜子太小了
Katrina: Our mirror is too small.
Katrina: 微微你醒了吗
Katrina: Tasha, are you awake?
Shure: 真的要吗
Shure: Do you really want to?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Choiszt: 要要偷看我呗
Choiszt: You want to peek at me, huh?
Shure: 呃脏倒是应该不脏
Shure: Uh, it shouldn't be dirty.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:你要打开门吗
Alice: Do you want to open the door?
Shure: 呃也不是
Shure: Uh, not really.
Shure: 就跟那个是一样的
Shure: It's just the same as that.
Choiszt: 这个前台手速那个翻个儿弄没了
Choiszt: The receptionist's quick hands flipped it away.
Shure: 对，主要是豆子香的
Shure: Yeah, mainly the beans smell good.
Choiszt: 还有两个你看
Choiszt: There are two more, look.
Alice:好进来吗
Alice: Should I come in?
Alice:哎呀我进不来
Alice: Oh no, I can't get in.
Shure: 就是1:16 对
Shure: It's 1:16, right.
Shure: 就是240克
Shure: It's 240 grams.
Katrina: 算了
Katrina: Forget it.
Choiszt: 在那个咖啡
Choiszt: In that coffee.
Shure: 官方建议然后对
Shure: Official recommendation, and yeah.
Katrina: 哎呀我这眼睛是有路的这个动作有一点点素
Katrina: Oh my, my eyes can see this move is a bit plain.
Shure: 大多数都是
Shure: Most of them are.
Lucia: 出来吧
Lucia: Come out.
Lucia: 刚站在这里看还没有看出来
Lucia: Just standing here watching, can't see it.
爱丽：那我先给你关上吧
Alice: Then I'll close it for you.
Shure: 忘给
Shure: Forgot to give.
Shure: 后天我的咖啡豆就到了就可以
Shure: My coffee beans will arrive the day after tomorrow, then we can.
Choiszt: 想象中
Choiszt: Imagining.
Katrina: 呵呵你看他都
Katrina: Haha, look at him.
Katrina: 真的要跳
Katrina: Really going to jump.
Lucia: 我这边反光刚好
Lucia: The reflection here is just right.
Lucia: 打在打在这个人上看不清楚
Lucia: It hits the person, can't see clearly.
Alice:要不要把那个窗帘放下来
Alice: Should we lower the curtains?
Katrina: 他手啊什么动作
Katrina: His hands and actions.
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong?
Choiszt: 八折亮度挑梁一点
Choiszt: The brightness at 80% is better.
Lucia: 或者我们现在需要用到这个这个灯吗
Lucia: Or do we need to use this light now?
Lucia: 这样
Lucia: Like this.
Katrina: 天呐我们像练习室啊
Katrina: Oh my, we look like a practice room.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 我们前面应该还有一个大镜子
Lucia: We should have a big mirror in front.
Lucia: 就更好了
Lucia: That would be even better.
Choiszt: 我给你们不光吧
Choiszt: I'll give you guys more.
Lucia: 这样就能
Lucia: This way we can...
Katrina: 你看他还挺快的
Katrina: Look, he's pretty fast.
Lucia: 哦可以可以
Lucia: Oh, that's great.
Lucia: 那个那个那个影楼灯
Lucia: That studio light...
Choiszt: 那个方案是人反过来
Choiszt: That plan is to reverse the person.
Lucia: 那个柔光板一定要加上
Lucia: We definitely need to add the soft light board.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 这动作感觉好陌生
Lucia: This move feels so unfamiliar.
Katrina: 是所以我在想要跳这个吗
Katrina: Yeah, so I'm thinking, do we need to dance this?
Katrina: 我怕对他们太难了
Katrina: I'm afraid it might be too hard for them.
Shure: 我们跳queencap吧
Shure: Let's dance Queencap.
Katrina: queencap跟这个不知道那个难
Katrina: Queencap, I don't know which is harder.
Lucia: 可以调
Lucia: We can adjust.
Katrina: queencap挑不好会很丑跳着好像那个大猩猩
Katrina: If Queencap isn't done well, it looks really ugly, like a big gorilla.
Shure: queencap
Shure: Queencap.
Katrina: 啊这个好小女
Katrina: Ah, this is so girly.
Shure: 如果我们看电影是在楼上看是吗
Shure: If we watch a movie, do we watch it upstairs?
Shure: 比如说想要看看个电影什么的
Shure: For example, if we want to watch a movie or something.
Katrina: 可以吃火锅的时候
Katrina: We can do it while eating hotpot.
Shure: 集体观影
Shure: Group viewing.
Jake:可以吃火锅就是光看电影没哟
Jake: We can eat hotpot, but just watching a movie, no.
Lucia: 我们可以把它投到这个上面吗
Lucia: Can we project it onto this?
Katrina: 把这个视频对
Katrina: Project this video, right.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Yes, yes.
Choiszt: 好像也行
Choiszt: Seems doable too.
Lucia: 这样是不是方便学一些
Lucia: Wouldn't this make it easier to learn?
Lucia: 只要这个灯打开
Lucia: As long as this light is on.
Lucia: 就是在屏幕上会有一个亮点
Lucia: There will be a bright spot on the screen.
Lucia: 然后我有点反光
Lucia: Then I'll get some reflection.
Shure: 可以啊可以
Shure: Yes, that's fine.
Lucia: 所以所以我看动作有点看不清楚
Lucia: So, so I can't see the moves clearly.
Shure: 投过了投过了
Shure: It's projected, it's projected.
Katrina: 偶买噶出道了哈哈
Katrina: Oh my god, debut, haha.
Lucia: 但有个问题是我们好像只能投5次
Lucia: But the problem is we can only project 5 times.
Lucia: 是不是应该把这个宝贵的机会啊
Lucia: Shouldn't we save this precious opportunity?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 这小米这个可以那什么
Shure: This Xiaomi one can do that.
Shure: 我来解决一下
Shure: I'll take care of it.
Jake:好你来解决一下
Jake: Okay, you handle it.
Katrina: 咱应该是只跳了1分 1分40
Katrina: We probably only skipped 1 minute 1 minute 40.
Katrina: 应该只跳了1分30
Katrina: We should have only skipped 1 minute 30.
Katrina: 差不多吧
Katrina: About that, right?
Katrina: 再再看一遍
Katrina: Let's watch it again.
Choiszt: 这这标准确实同还
Choiszt: The standard is indeed the same.
Shure: 我感觉你好像长高了哦没哟
Shure: I feel like you've grown taller, oh no.
Choiszt: 这
Choiszt: This...
Shure: 他怎么又变成这个德行了
Shure: Why has he become like this again?
Shure: 好像那个送孩子来上跳舞课
Shure: It's like taking a kid to a dance class.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后在后面等着
Shure: And then waiting in the back.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 像吗
Shure: Does it look like that?
Lucia: 我要换双鞋子
Lucia: I need to change my shoes.
Lucia: 不行这个这个
Lucia: No, this one, this one...
Lucia: 等一下我如果戴着眼镜进去
Lucia: Wait, if I wear glasses inside,
Lucia: 是不是他就拍到我
Lucia: Will he film me?
Lucia: 乱七八糟的箱子
Lucia: With the messy boxes?
Katrina: 没事我已经拍过很多遍
Katrina: It's okay, I've filmed it many times.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Choiszt: 也许就是这样昂
Choiszt: Maybe that's just how it is.
Katrina: 差不多学到这
Katrina: That's about it for now.
Katrina: 差不多我觉得已经很很多
Katrina: I think we've learned a lot already.
Katrina: 没有只学了一分半看那个
Katrina: It's not just learning for 1.5 minutes, look at that.
Katrina: 要不直接一起跟着学
Katrina: How about we just learn together?
Shure: 早上好夜之城
Shure: Good morning, Night City.
Alice:早上好
Alice: Good morning.
Katrina: 我也要换血
Katrina: I need to change my shoes too.
Katrina: 穿拖鞋带裤
Katrina: Wearing slippers with pants.
Shure: 昨天的死人乐透
Shure: Yesterday's dead lottery.
Katrina: 确定学这个了吗
Katrina: Are we sure we're learning this?
Katrina: 有有意义吗
Katrina: Is it meaningful?
Katrina: 感觉这个有一点点小难
Katrina: It feels a little bit difficult.
Katrina: 但是只要大家有决心
Katrina: But as long as everyone is determined,
Katrina: 就肯定能有学会
Katrina: We can definitely learn it.
Shure: 你怎么还PUA我们呢
Shure: Why are you still PUA-ing us?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 其实还有一个
Katrina: Actually, there's one more thing.
Katrina: 你今天看群里了吗
Katrina: Did you check the group chat today?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 稍微再低一点头
Shure: Lower your head a bit.
Katrina: 还有一个goodtime和
Katrina: There’s also a goodtime and...
Choiszt: 这个不要动
Choiszt: Don't move this.
Choiszt: 这个要跳的
Choiszt: This one needs to jump.
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 好他现在不动了
Shure: Alright, it's not moving now.
Katrina: 这简单
Katrina: This is easy.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这可能会学的比较有成就感
Katrina: This might feel quite rewarding to learn.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 拖鞋都快让我跳的甩出去了
Lucia: My slippers almost flew off from jumping.
Lucia: 换一个跟脚一点
Lucia: Let’s switch to something more secure.
Lucia: 这个腿要换吗不用换
Lucia: Do we need to change this leg? No need.
Shure: 操我的
Shure: Damn, my...
Shure: 我的我的我的
Shure: Mine, mine, mine.
Shure: b站怎么不堪入目呢
Shure: Why is Bilibili so inappropriate?
Shure: 有点哈哈
Shure: A bit, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 没没有关系
Shure: No, it's okay.
Shure: 你发我我直接点链接进去吧
Shure: Send it to me, I'll just click the link directly.
Shure: 叫啥呀这个
Shure: What's this called?
Katrina: 这个吗？偶像万万岁
Katrina: This? Idol Forever.
Shure: 教那些小知识
Shure: Teaching those little tips.
Lucia: 我觉得这个不错
Lucia: I think this one is nice.
Katrina: 要不跳这个吧
Katrina: How about we do this one?
Lucia: 因为他的动作重复
Lucia: Because the actions repeat.
Shure: 他叫什么
Shure: What's it called?
Lucia: 重复率很高
Lucia: It has a high repetition rate.
Shure: 他叫什么这个
Shure: What’s it called?
Katrina: 偶像万万岁
Katrina: Chasing Idol Forever.
Shure: 偶像
Shure: Idol...
Katrina: 你要跳那个吗
Katrina: Do you want to do that one?
Nicous: 对那个挑战
Nicous: Yes, that challenge.
Katrina: 投票吧
Katrina: Let's vote.
Nicous: 男的来个难一些的
Nicous: The guys should do something harder.
Katrina: 不是这个版本
Katrina: Not this version.
Katrina: 这是原男团版本
Katrina: This is the original boy band version.
Lucia: 什么刚那个是原版吗哈哈
Lucia: Was that the original version? Haha.
Nicous: 成年人的那个
Nicous: The adult one.
Katrina: yes
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 反是这个
Katrina: It's this one.
Katrina: 掉
Katrina: Drop.
Nicous: 我们搞定颜值卧槽
Nicous: We got the looks down, damn.
Lucia: 掉针了
Lucia: The needle dropped.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Nicous: 这太简单了
Nicous: This is too easy.
Katrina: 真的
Katrina: Really.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Nicous: 这没有那个前段时间条那个
Nicous: It doesn't have that part from earlier.
Shure: 七彩阳光吗这不
Shure: Isn't this "Colorful Sunshine"?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Nicous: 整理他没有
Nicous: He didn't organize it.
Shure: 广场舞级别
Shure: Square dance level.
Shure: 这个我要Queencard
Shure: I want Queencard for this.
Katrina: 决定一下吧
Katrina: Make a decision.
Katrina: 今天下午讨论一下
Katrina: Let's discuss this afternoon.
Shure: 还有分成
Shure: There's also a split.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 爱心
Katrina: Love.
Lucia: 这次就爱心了
Lucia: This time it's love.
Lucia: 真的很难说短剧和这个谁尬哈
Lucia: It's really hard to say which is more awkward, the short skit or this.
Nicous: 我说实话这个跳的真的蛮尬的
Nicous: Honestly, this dance is awkward
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Nicous: 说多没哦了
Nicous: No more talking.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 说实话跳这个是态度不行
Shure: Honestly, the attitude is wrong for this dance.
Shure: 跳yes OK
Shure: Dancing "yes" is OK.
Nicous: 我的妈这还有火锅
Nicous: Oh my god, there's hotpot too.
Shure: 是能力不行
Shure: It's the skill that's lacking.
Shure: 我靠吓住了
Shure: Whoa, that scared me.
Shure: 我们先拿这个热身好吧
Shure: Let's warm up with this first, okay?
Katrina: 好的看来你们还是想学那个是吧
Katrina: Alright, seems like you guys still want to learn that one, right?
Shure: 哎呀操哈哈
Shure: Oh my, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 这个有3分钟
Katrina: This one is 3 minutes long.
Katrina: 那个是只跳1分钟
Katrina: That one only jumps for 1 minute.
Lucia: 哈sorry
Lucia: Ha sorry
Nicous: 还他妈有啊
Nicous: There's still more?
Katrina: 课间操没这么短哈哈哈哈
Katrina: The break exercises aren't this short hahaha
Lucia: 不是怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 为什么又开始跑步
Lucia: Why are we running again?
Katrina: 啊有点累
Katrina: Ah, a bit tired.
Lucia: 这运动量其实也不小呢
Lucia: This exercise is actually not small.
Katrina: 喔
Katrina: Oh
Nicous: 直接趴在这里直接趴在这里
Nicous: Just lie down here, lie down here.
Katrina: 你不要紧
Katrina: Are you okay?
Nicous: 太累了
Nicous: Too tired.
Katrina: 太简单了
Katrina: Too easy.
Katrina: 哈那咱眺yesok吧
Katrina: Haha then let's jump yesok.
Katrina: 这样被
Katrina: Like this?
Jake:就学完了是吧
Jake: So, we're done learning?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Lucia: 他们已经这个顺利学会了
Lucia: They have already learned this smoothly.
Shure: 觉得这个没有难度
Shure: I think this is not challenging.
Alice:会了
Alice: Got it.
Shure: 我们需要学学有一点东西的东西
Shure: We need to learn something a bit more challenging.
Katrina: yesok
Katrina: Yesok
Shure: 哎我的b站又烂掉了
Shure: Oh no, my Bilibili is broken again.
Lucia: 或者我们跳worthit这个我也复习起来能快一点
Lucia: Or we can dance Worth It, I can review it quickly.
Katrina: worth it的感觉是很早很早前的舞了
Katrina: Worth It feels like a dance from a long time ago.
Shure: 呦
Shure: Oh
Katrina: 高中的时候就跳
Katrina: Danced it in high school.
Shure: 你还没有开
Shure: You haven't started yet.
Katrina: 啦啦啦wasit
Katrina: Lalala was it
Jake:你没开
Jake: You didn't start.
Shure: 你先把这退出一遍
Shure: Exit this first.
Lucia: 所以其实也忘得差不多了
Lucia: So I actually forgot most of it.
Shure: 让再进去
Shure: Then go back in.
Lucia: 但是比学个新的能快一点
Lucia: But it's faster than learning a new one.
Jake:那一会再看一次
Jake: Then watch it again later.
Katrina: 所以
Katrina: So
Katrina: 呃我想想本来备选还有什么来着
Katrina: Uh let me think, what else did we prepare?
Katrina: 奔跑的青春和
Katrina: Running youth and...
Lucia: 哎奔跑青春可以让他们去跳那个solo
Lucia: Hey, running youth, let's have them do that solo dance.
Nicous: 再跳吧我要解除封印了
Nicous: Dance again, I'm about to unleash the seal.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:啊你要干嘛了
Jake: Ah, what are you doing?
Shure: 要脱光膀子了是吧啊
Shure: Are you going to take off your shirt?
Nicous: 爱啊好好跳
Nicous: Love it, dance properly.
Katrina: 那就跳这个黑色的
Katrina: Then let's dance this black one.
Katrina: 哎为什么声音这么小
Katrina: Hey, why is the sound so low?
Jake:声音可以弄大一点
Jake: You can turn up the volume.
Katrina: 我我已经调到最大了
Katrina: I already turned it up to the max.
Shure: 最大了
Shure: It's maxed out.
Nicous: 就隔着学舞
Nicous: Just learn the dance from here.
Katrina: 对这是教学
Katrina: Yes, this is a tutorial.
Nicous: 我觉着不用教学可以直接跳
Nicous: I think we can skip the tutorial and just dance.
Katrina: 真假哈哈惊呆了
Katrina: Really? Haha, I'm shocked.
Shure: 哎呀卧槽
Shure: Oh, damn.
Jake:好了哦行
Jake: Alright, okay.
Shure: 太sex了吧这个
Shure: This is too sexy, right?
Katrina: 这正常的绝世元素
Katrina: These are the normal top elements.
Jake:来也跳啊
Jake: Come on, dance too.
Jake:你们跳一跳
Jake: You guys dance a bit.
Katrina: 2234
Katrina: 5 5678
Lucia: 哎怎么又校准一次
Lucia: Hey, why calibrate again?
Jake:怎么又叫
Jake: Why call again?
Jake:因为刚刚有没有开
Jake: Because it wasn't on just now.
Katrina: 刚开始是背过去的23456
Katrina: At the beginning, it was turned away, 23456.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Katrina: 5678
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: I see.
Katrina: 33456784234
Alice:已经四个吧拍了
Alice: We already recorded four of them.
Lucia: 把这个往后推一推
Lucia: Push this one back a bit.
Katrina: 12345678223456783234567
Katrina: 678
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 哪一部我不会了
Shure: Which part? I can't do it.
Nicous: 太简单了
Nicous: It's too simple.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 等一下这个是
Lucia: Wait a second, this is
Nicous: 卧槽哈哈
Nicous: Whoa, haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina: 你不是要跳这个
Katrina: Weren't you going to dance to this?
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This one
Shure: me ro me ro me ro
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:我问你没开
Jake: I asked you, is it not on?
Jake:你没电了吗看一下
Jake: Are you out of battery? Check it out
Jake:all
Jake: All
Jake:right
Jake: Right
Jake:对这是一个
Jake: Yes, this is one
Shure: 行了这
Shure: Alright, this
Katrina: music直接给
Katrina: Just give the music directly
Nicous: 快点的快点的
Nicous: Hurry up, hurry up
Shure: 1234567822345678323456784234567耶
Shure: 1234567822345678323456784234567 Yeah
Shure: 洒洒水
Shure: Easy peasy
Katrina: 一倍速
Katrina: Normal speed
Shure: 三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Three four five six seven eight two two three four five
Shure: 六七八三二三四五
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four five
Shure: 六七八四二三四跑
Shure: Six seven eight four two three four run
Shure: yes OK
Shure: Yes, OK
Shure: 二三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight two two three four five
Shure: 六七八三二三四顶
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four top
Shure: 二四二三四
Shure: Two four two three four
Lucia: 我们已经自动有了代教老师了
Lucia: We already have an automatic substitute teacher
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 一二三四
Shure: One two three four
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Katrina: 厉害搞艺术
Katrina: Impressive, doing art
Shure: 是不是武士就是都是这个样子
Shure: Aren't all samurais like this?
Katrina: 没吃早饭
Katrina: Haven't had breakfast
Nicous: 我觉得咱么可以直接快进到1倍速
Nicous: I think we can directly fast forward to normal speed
Katrina: 12
Katrina: 啊哈突然把屁股顶了出去
Katrina: Ah, suddenly sticking out your butt
Shure: 1234
Shure: 56
Katrina: 啊不好意思不好意思
Katrina: Ah, sorry, sorry
Shure: 5678
Shure: 12345678
Katrina: 234